Congresswoman Nancy Pelosi will no
longer be in leadership she is currently
the Speaker of the House that
speakership is set to end when
Republicans take control of the house in
January of 2023 and Nancy Pelosi
announced on the floor of the house
yesterday she is not going to be seeking
a leadership role but she will be
staying in Congress the Associated Press
reporting that this is a quote pivotal
realignment making way for a new
generation of leaders Nancy Pelosi gave
a speech she said that first of all she
has led democrats for nearly 20 years
secondly she is dealing with the
aftermath of this brutal attack on her
husband Paul Pelosi last month in the
San Francisco home she was the first
female speaker of the house and she will
not seek any leadership role starting in
January she says we must move boldly
into the future I will not seek
re-election to Democratic Leadership in
the next Congress for me the hours come
for a new generation to lead the
Democratic caucus that I so deeply
respect she received a standing ovation
and it is not typical that a party
leader stays on after withdrawing from
the leadership she was re-elected and
there is much speculation about whether
this will be her final two-year term she
is 82 years old
um we don't know the answer to that but
Nancy Pelosi made it clear and it is
horrifying when you are influenced in
your plans
by such a horrifying attack like what
happened to Paul Pelosi because to some
degree you feel as though you're I'm
letting them push me out but there were
already questions about Nancy Pelosi's
future
whatever you think about her politics
and I am to Nancy Pelosi's left
you have to recognize not only the
significance as the first female speaker
of the house but her 20-year tenure in
Democratic Leadership
and her ability to get things done
they're not necessarily the most
exciting things always they're not
necessarily the things I would
prioritize but she did understand how
the House of Representatives worked and
while I have taken issue with Nancy
Pelosi so many times on specifics
um quite a career quite a career so
Nancy Pelosi stepping down from
leadership will stay in the House of
Representatives
Fox News is now targeting John
fetterman's wife this is a real study in
character assassination as carried out
by the American right wing and media
apparatus let's look at the clips first
and then I'm going to explain
um Aaron rupar assembled what was a
roughly 24-hour period
of attacks on Giselle fetterman take a
look at this going after Senator is
Senator elect John fetterman's wife
Giselle after she'd posted this pic many
were quick to point out that her husband
is partially cropped out
and accused Mrs fetterman of using it
for her own 15 minutes of fame okay so
so far it's all fun and games right but
let's continue one critic said she
wanted this so badly for herself LOL
another first day for Senator elect
Gisele fetterman and why is she even
there your thoughts
well she's a lot better looking than he
is so as a man who's married to a wife
that is far better looking I'm sure John
fetterman would say I don't even need to
be in this photo but he's not able to do
the job Harris and uh and the reality
here is that it does feel as if
basically Pennsylvania has elected his
wife and she certainly is furthering
that idea uh with these photos maybe
she's going to step down oh so even
though it's a joke there's still a truth
in this and now listen to this
conspiracy theory I'll back up back it
up a few seconds his wife and she
certainly is furthering that idea uh
with these photos that maybe she's going
to step down and the new democrat
governor-elect is going to end up
appointing her when her husband can't do
the job uh what I I still in Paris that
we could ever be in a situation where
John fetterman got elected in
Pennsylvania it's an utter failure of
pennsylvanians that he's their
representative well look uh every
Republican uh lawmaker that's dissecting
this that your interview will tell you
that they're going to take a close look
at how polling was wrong they really
want to know what happened not just in
this race because what happened is Oz
lost that's what happened so max
Kennerly explains the mechanism that is
at play here Fox does it and many do it
okay this is Max writes this segment is
a case study of the four-part Fox News
method number one pick a villain
preferably a woman and or minority
Giselle immigrated from Brazil okay
that's number one number two find
something innocuous the fettermans have
a long-running gag about John not
fitting in pictures so the fact that in
the picture she posted John fetterman is
only partially in the picture it's a
known gag it's a thing that they've had
going for a while it's it's just a joke
okay then Max counterly goes on to
explain number three is you reframe the
innocuous thing as contemptible
and the fact that John fetterman only
partially is in the picture even though
it's a long-running joke is because
Giselle is self-centered it's because
maybe she's really in charge it's maybe
because fetterman can't do the job
because of his stroke Etc and then part
four is you inject that completely
deranged conspiracy theory which is John
is actually incapacitated and there's a
plot for him to resign and then Josh
Shapiro who defeated Doug mastriano to
become the next Governor will appoint
Giselle fetterman to be the next senator
from Pennsylvania that's that's the
four-part system
that's really what's contemptible and
unfortunately because you and I we
understand the parts and we go okay
here's how they go from one to two to
three to four a lot of the Fox News
viewers will just focus on that last
thing yeah you know what this is a plot
fetterman can't do the job because of
the stroke
and so this is all to make yourself
betterment an immigrant from Brazil
woman of color a senator even though she
wasn't elected there's no evidence for
that obviously uh this stuff works Max
Kennerly doing a good job of explaining
how
I want to revisit something we talked
about earlier in the week
and we talked about it with Angelo
Carrison from Media Matters and we've
talked about it in other contexts
is Fox News actually turning on Donald
Trump
our best assessment up until November
7th was Fox News isn't really turning on
Trump but they'd rather someone else be
the nominee they'd rather be done with
Trump
and they are setting up Escape hatches
where they can hit the eject button if
necessary
I'm starting to wonder whether Fox News
is going more in the direction of openly
turning on Trump now there's a very
interesting clip wherein Stuart Varney
interviews Trump's daughter-in-law Lara
Trump now this is particularly
interesting because Lara Trump is a Fox
News contributor so this is not just a
guest this is a Fox anchor interviewing
a fox employee Lara Trump and he brings
to her Varney does that announcement on
Tuesday night
didn't seem very good it really didn't
seem particularly good and it's
interesting the way this conversation
goes take a look so I'm sure you're very
supportive of of your father-in-law but
those of us on the outside looking at it
it didn't seem as he got the old magic
you know what I mean
oh well I highly disagree with that look
for Donald Trump from the very beginning
from the first day he came down the
escalator in 2015. right that's the
famous speech where he talked about
Mexican rapists in Trump Tower it's
never been about elected officials
politicians people uh you know in the
swamp in DC it's been about the American
people and if you look around the room
last night you had people from all
different walks of life the energy there
at Mar-A-Lago was absolutely incredible
it really did to me feel like the
2015-2016 campaign all over again okay
so this is Trump's daughter-in-law and a
Fox News contributor who is paid for
that commentary that you just saw but
there was no energy in the room I mean
we we looked at the clips the energy was
so bad people were trying to leave and
Mar-A-Lago staff were keeping them in
the room the energy was so bad that
Jonathan Carl from ABC while Trump was
speaking was able to deliver a live
stand-up report not talking particularly
literally loudly because it was so dead
in the room so there may be something
different going on I think it's too
early to know remember from a couple
days ago Maria Bartiromo who has been
one of the biggest Trump suck-ups for
years now there's no Trump conspiracy
theory too crazy for Maria she hosted a
segment wherein she brought guests on
and even she made comments that are kind
of like we might be over Trump that's
that's that thing that people keep
pushing back on they don't want to go
into a whole nother storm of hate and
there is Trump derangement syndrome
right there's definitely and and I think
he started even that last night he
started with the China virus he started
with you know poking names at DeSantis
we've heard that and people are tired of
it look I also think that you know the
santis and youngin like you said are
really the future of the party right
they're they're in a generation that I
think needs to come forward and as much
as you know his policies were good
Trump's office is good in the first in
the first term I don't think the
majority of the country really wants to
go back there I'll tell you I live in
Florida Florida's fully behind the
Santos no matter what Trump wants to
tell you they're fully behind the
scientist you know what's interesting
Ivanka Trump Ivanka Trump yesterday says
she's bowing out of politics yeah which
we covered extensively already so listen
I'll leave the question to you is Fox
News proactively bailing on Donald Trump
or are they just leaving themselves an
exit let me know in the comments make
sure that you were subscribed on on
YouTube three million of you 3.2 million
of you last month watch the videos
didn't subscribe let's chip away at that
and get to 2 million subscribers make
sure you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel quick break back after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show is of course an
audience funded program you can sign up
at joinpakman.com the new coupon code
please no more Trump and you you type it
with no spaces but you have to think of
it in your head as please no more Trump
it's like a desperation that the guy not
be president again that code will save
you bigly and you can use it at
joinpakman.com let's hear from people in
the audience the most important people
because without you I'm a guy in a room
with a mic and no one's listening and
it's sad okay we don't want that let's
start today with rose I guess calling
from the United States is that you Rose
yes can you hear me clearly yes the
United States is so General you could
you could be anywhere you know
it's true uh privacy preserving so um
did you watch the launch of uh dsls and
the Artemis One mission you know I did
not see it but I saw you know a little
bit of a replay
oh it was it was unexpectedly moving and
spectacular like the plume itself from
the rocket was like a mile long yes
that's a lot of pollution it sounds like
rose
well I don't say it's hydrogen and
oxygen so it's more St ionized gases
it's just water vapor oh is that right
is that true
uh the first stage is hydrogen oxygen
the solid rocket boosters they they do
burn uh fuel
um but yeah most of the output is just
water so well if that's true then I like
water water is good
yeah
um the question I wanted to ask was that
it took us
um
11 years at this point 10 years a decade
to get to this launch and the program so
far has cost around
27.5
billion dollars yeah in in 2022 right
and
I am I I'm just it and the reason why we
have this is like a 62.5 offer Twitter
so in like Elon units
um the so the reason why we have that is
because a single senator from the great
city of Alabama Senator Shelby I wanted
to save jobs in a state so we have an
entire 27.5 billion dollar program
because of him not because like
people at Nasa wanted to do this and
this was the best technical Way Forward
but mostly because of uh Congressional
and Senate interference in the process
um have you given thought to how we can
get past this kind of corruption
well I would like to see one of the
things in general I mean I can't speak
to the exact process you're describing
because I did not follow it clearly as
closely as you did but one of the things
I would prefer to see when it comes to
everything in Under the Umbrella of
Science and I would include space
exploration there is if there could be
a way to de-politicize some of the
decisions like of course the jobs for a
lot of the spending will
disproportionately be in some states and
not others that there's no real way
around that you're not going to be able
to say let's do space exploration and
divide the money equally among 50 states
it's not going to happen so I know
sorry uh so if you're presenting a
contract like when Boeing presents a
contract or even SpaceX they actually
make sure that they have suppliers from
all 50 states
what do they have from North Dakota for
this project
uh like uh something from torque not to
something there's a list of suppliers
that's great but I think the point still
stands that you don't have exactly equal
dollar for dollar in job for job
division across all 50 states so there's
going to be some elected officials that
will be more incentivized than others
maybe to go with a particular approach I
don't know if we need a nonpartisan
advisory committee which there I'm sure
it probably exists at least in some name
but clearly it's not effective enough
because you still get these extremely
political uh outcomes I don't know what
it is it's something that needs to be
equivalent to the ways we could re draw
districts more fairly but I would love
to see more scientists involved in
figuring out rather than doing it this
way which is most appealing to these
Senators we should do it this way which
is actually where the most exciting
potential rewards exist based on where
the science is and I don't know what the
answer is Rose as to exactly how you do
that
so
um in Europe
um like CERN for example gets a specific
uh inflation or just a contribution from
member states member states get to get
sent people to their uh Council which
sits on top and like basically votes on
spending Decisions by CERN uh if CERN
wants to build a big particle collider
they start decades in advance like
they've already started for uh saving
money and setting aside debt and
financing and everything else for a
client that's going to be built in the
2040s to the 2050s right so they plan in
like a 30 40 year time Horizon NASA is
constrained by the yearly budget and
they have to spend every single penny in
that yearly budget and they're not
allowed to save money that makes sense
yep absolutely that I I totally
understand that mechanism I I do think
that having to plan 30 or 40 30 years
ahead also makes the the progress at
least seems slower and I don't know if
that will work for an American audience
that wants to see action more quickly
but I think we should explore all of
these options and I really appreciate
the call Rose
pleasure talking
to you there is Rose from the United
States let's go to Dean from Dallas
Texas Dean welcome to the program what's
on your mind today
hey David can you hear me I can
uh I was wondering are you familiar with
South Korean politics at all only in
passing
so South Korea has kind of had a
historical problem with their presidents
they've sent Lee Myung back for
embezzlement and bribery he's gone to
jail for a long time parking has a
female president she's been to jail for
abuse of power bribery coercion leaking
government secrets even the former
president Moon he's under investigation
he he could go to jail my question is to
uh
why a democratic country like South
Korea has no issues Prosecuting and
jailing former presidents and
politicians politicians but the U.S
can't
do you think culture and tradition Trump
law I do I do and you know if you go to
my birth country of Argentina you'll see
there is also a long tradition of uh
corruption and arguable criminality from
presidents and leaders and uh the the
last one the previous one seems almost
always to be under investigation and the
Dynamics within countries I think
sometimes maybe the right term is that
there are these
uh over time implicitly it's not like
people sit down and say here we jail
former leaders and then in another
country people sit down and say here we
do not jail former leaders I believe
that it's small decisions over time that
are a combination of
how the judicial system and court system
the Judiciary is set up
how judges are chosen
uh cultural attitudes towards misdeeds
by elected officials all these little
things together lead to some countries
where it's completely typical that uh
you you jail former leaders and others
where you don't it also exists in the US
at the state by state level I mean look
at New Jersey's history of Prosecuting
former governors which I mean you could
say well they've had a lot of more
criminality among former Jersey
governors compared to another state but
there also seems to be something there
about expectation so I think it's all of
these things
okay so you think like the fear of
public retribution or violence impacts
our justice system that I don't know
specifically it's it's possible that's
possible but we'd really have to ask
more to understand people's attitudes
but I think there is a cultural
component and there's also a sort of
cumulative component over time related
to expectations
okay well thanks for uh taking my call
all right Dean from Dallas thank you
very very much for the call let's go
next to Tristan from Oregon Tristan
welcome to the program
hi Davey can you hear me yes I can
hi David
um it's been a long time since I've
called your show I'm I'm the blind guy
who called your show a couple years ago
during the height of the pandemic I was
uh dealing with some back backlog
grocery issues at the time okay
great to hear from you again oh thank
you thank you um so two questions one's
much more relevant relevant than the
other
um
I know on one of your recent streamed
you
you said that you were a fan of
chocolate babka I just got recently
introduced to the world of chocolate
vodkas via Trader Joe's and I just
wanted to get your opinion like is that
Trader Joe's chocolate bottle because
any good I have no idea I've never had
it I've never had it
um you know I I do think that I don't
know what the situation necessarily is
where you are as far as babka goes but
if you could find like a Jewish deli
that has babka I might go there before I
go to Trader Joe's but maybe the Trader
Joe's chocolate babka is fine
I mean I've already tried it is
excellent of the highest order I must
say so I imagine I imagine the Jewish
deli would be otherworldly in other
words maybe so yeah but listen it's it's
good it's good if you can find it at all
I think that's a good start yeah
definitely definitely
um but onto my next question uh just
given all of this sort of atmosphere
that we have in this country and Trump's
announcement on Tuesday yep
um
just with everything going on and this
is very sort of philosophical esoteric
question
um my favorite type of question
yeah
um how much time do you think we've
bought American democracy just in terms
of the election and Trump's announcement
you're saying with his announcement how
much time we bought
well just the totality of it the
election and and his announcement and
just the general political sort of
atmosphere I mean listen I don't for me
it's so the results of the midterms to
some degree
are reassuring although Republicans are
still taking the house and they almost
took the Senate but they didn't and you
know it's going to be two years of
gridlock but to some degree at least
enough people cared about the outcome to
hold off an actual Red Wave
on the other hand with Trump's
announcement Trump's announcement itself
was pretty dystopian but what I'm a
little bit reassured by is how boring
everybody in the room found it and how
in all the polling that's recent Trump
seems to be losing in most of the polls
to DeSantis who hasn't even announced
its candidacy so I have like a small
cautious optimism that the Republican
party is ready to be done with Trump
yeah I'm hopeful I had to actually tune
away from his his announcement because I
just I was falling asleep it was
incredible it was a lot of the same
stuff he's been doing at the rallies but
presented in a more boring monotone
combined with I'm running for president
it was very strange very very strange
yeah I'm not I'm not quite sure yeah
um do you think that like if Trump loses
in the primaries to DeSantis or somebody
else do you think he's gonna keep
claiming fraud or do you think he's
gonna pivot somehow I hope that he runs
as an independent if that happens just
because it would be so terrible for the
Republican party I don't I'm not you
know kind of holding my breath but it
would be amazing for for Trump to just
run as an independent take like 15
percent of the Republican vote and
prevent the Republican nominee from
winning that would be great
yeah you you definitely have a point
there I hope he does too well that's all
I had then Tristan remind me of your
blindness tell me about it are you I
just don't remember are you completely
blind
I am completely blind and both eyes have
been since I was born yeah so you this
is if I I know that this is not new
ground but like if I say to you that
like the background of my set is blue
does that have any meaning to you
uh yeah I mean like so just throughout
my lifetime I've just kind of been able
to contextualize what colors are I
remember like asking my dad what is
black like what is red like and you know
red is like the bright
you know sort of you know I remember
being on you know describing it while I
was engaged in some substances like man
it's like it's like you're it's loud to
the eyes and you know Lou is kind of
like it's softer but it has a bright
color it's hard it's interesting they
have some meaning to me but it it it it
can it can be a little tricky but and
and yeah and so you have no idea what I
look like right
not really no I mean I know you've
described yourself a little bit but I
don't have any idea what you look like
now interesting very very interesting
wow uh well Tristan listen I appreciate
you calling in and uh we're gonna keep
an eye it sounds like you and I are
keeping an eye on a lot of the same
things so I appreciate it all right
thanks so much David you take care you
too there is Tristan from Oregon great
to hear from him let's go uh why don't
we go next I mean why not right let's go
to Bryce from Scotland Bryce welcome
can you hear me fine
you sound like you're completely
underwater your audio is totally muddled
okay uh I will do my best to try oh
that's a little better
oh God yeah
oh boy second
well what was your question Bryce let's
see if we can understand each other
[Music]
uh right I'll do I'll do my best yeah uh
not trying to be too pessimistic but um
do you think there's
a way at all obviously you've probably
seen the joke that UK Paul takes is at
the minute
with three prime ministers in seven
weeks
sorry what's happening in seven weeks
Bryce
oh sorry uh let me
I am impressed I'm gonna let you go for
now just because the audio is it's it's
not maybe it's me I might be having an
issue
but um I'm gonna let you go for now and
let's see if we can let's see if we can
reset uh let's try uh oh I don't know
how about Nate from Rhode Island what's
going on Nate
hey David how you doing I'm doing well
so I had a question for you it's not as
mainstream but it's about the Second
Amendment so now the first uh sentence
of the Second Amendment states uh about
uh regulation about regulated militia
does that mean we can regulate them to
the point of like Japan for instance
like and not not to say that I doubt
this quote credit Court wouldn't strike
it down but what do you think about that
no so the a lot of those semantic Second
Amendment arguments have all kind of
been explored and and they're just kind
of retreads so I I don't know the answer
to that there it's not where I would be
focusing my activism on gun safety
regulation I would be focusing on let's
do the things we know we can do that
don't depend on the linguistic
um nuances of how it's written and
instead say like we got a eliminate the
possibility of any gun sales without a
background check we've got to limit high
capacity magazines you know we have this
full list I would focus there instead of
on these linguistic concerns okay well
thank you I just had that thought in my
head for a little while and wanted to
get that out thank you so much for
taking my call appreciate it very much
let's take a very quick break we're
going right back to the phone so if
you're holding on to talk to me don't
hang up and we'll get back in just a
minute
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to Discord and talk to a few more
people uh davidpackman.com Discord is
the place to find it why don't we go
next to Thomas from Denmark Thomas
welcome to the program
thank you David
um just a quick question about
um gun laws and um how a republic a
Republicans they uh they view it
types like Ted Cruz what will you what
do you think it will take to
to change
um the way they
um they look on condos or how sorry
sorry it doesn't do it
um oh it's not prepared
Thomas
uh oh and Thomas
is gone
oh boy
uh all right let's try I hope this is
correct geray from Atlanta is that how I
pronounce it
pronounce uh you're okay from Atlanta
welcome gyro I apologize
uh so I was in an argument within an
election and I was telling him how the
burn of proof is on the people claiming
that the election is false and he made
like a point about how like people on a
ride just don't trust the elections and
I told them the reason they don't trust
him is because political figures like
Trump tell them that they can't trust it
correct and he brought up a point how uh
like Trump was since supported the
vaccine was telling me is supporters to
get it uh but they didn't really like
blindly follow him on that issue I
didn't know how to cure it so I was
trying to ask like how you would counter
that
you it doesn't it doesn't need to be
countered I mean it's just they're two
different things so on the vaccines the
issue was
Trump initially convinced some people on
vaccines by saying he developed them
okay but then the rollout of the
vaccines was mostly under Joe Biden so
then a lot of them were able to kind of
off-ramp by saying well
it's not it's less about the vaccines
per se which Trump did do a good job in
developing but it's about how they're
being forced upon me by Joe Biden so for
a lot of it was just a different
situation when it comes to the election
stuff they got the idea that it was
stolen from the things Trump said and
Mike pillow and Sydney Powell and Rooney
Giuliani I mean where else would they
get it where else would they get it and
then on the vaccine thing if you present
them with what what we're talking about
here a lot of them would say well I was
able to do my own research on the
vaccines like the research is a joke and
it's nonsense but when it comes to the
election stuff it's not about research
they did it's just quite literally the
stuff that Trump and others have been
saying so I don't even really get the
Ana it's one of these kind of weird
analogies that doesn't really make any
sense
got you thank you
all right thank you very much for the
call appreciate hearing from our friends
in Georgia remember to vote remember to
vote in Georgia let's go to Kevin from
San Diego Kevin welcome what's on your
mind
hi there David
um first of all say sir thank you for
telling me to go to Puesto last time I
was there it was uh incredible oh my god
did you get the brisket taco
uh I did not did you say the brisket
Taco I got the I got the filet mignon
tacos I got the I got the ones with the
filet mignon and uh Lobster in them and
they were
it was like the best tacos I've ever had
that sounds criminal that sounds
criminal yeah no it's it should be
criminalized honestly but uh anyway
um okay on on that that's that's a
that's a good thing that's happened but
uh unfortunately we seem to be sliding
towards uh a bit of a bit of a fascism
um here
um I'm thinking that like do you agree
that it would be
it would be best if we had like Trump V
DeSantis get really ugly and they I
don't know if other people have talked
about this before I joined a little late
but nobody has talked about it other
than me earlier in the week I my concern
with this entire primary that is
building wherein Trump has announced
then DeSantis hasn't but there's polls
where he's already winning DeSantis that
is my priority is whatever scenario will
get these people to destroy themselves
and each other and right now the most
likely destructive path forward is you
have a very ugly primary wherein the
Trump and the DeSantis people if
DeSantis runs hate each other so that
when hopefully DeSantis wins the primary
and the reason I say that is DeSantis
won't go and run third party but Trump
might DeSantis was the primary Trump
goes and runs third party takes a bunch
of his supporters because they hate
DeSantis and just splits the vote and a
Democrat easily wins that to me seems
like the dream scenario right now
yeah I mean and I think that Trump is
probably aware that that could happen
but he's still too like arrogant and
narcissistic to not do it if he doesn't
take the primary in the first place like
that's why he doesn't win
I I don't see any way he he just like
lets it Go and doesn't
yeah he's he because he's he's just he's
just too crazy to not do that I believe
that you are exactly right which is
Trump may be so narcissistic that even
if he intellectually understands or has
people around him saying you will just
hand this to a Democrat if you run third
party I hope he does it anyway
right yeah well we're getting ahead of
ourselves the first question is does he
win the primary we're assuming he
doesn't he still might
yeah he still might and that would be
bad I just think that like there's
enough things where the Republicans are
like kind of even if even not counting
the the current primary there's like the
the Supreme Court of morvi Harper I
don't remember exactly what which the
one that was um that that's deciding
things so that the states can make their
own things with no federal their own
election rules with no federal oversight
indeed um
which if that is decided by the court in
favor of like the what the Republicans
want
um I feel like there's a bunch of states
that are just going to be like oh yes
the Republicans won again no matter what
uh basically they're gonna make rules to
to not necessarily to
you know decide the elections against
what people actually voted but
essentially suppress enough of the vote
and uh make it to only the places that
they know are going to be voting for
Republicans are going to account
essentially indeed and uh then they'll
they'll never be won by anyone uh
anywhere close to Progressive again
that is a horrible uh uh worth it's
horrible what you're saying but it's a
few steps ahead so let's Reserve
judgment and see what happens next if
that makes sense uh yeah well it's not
bad to think about it just to plan ahead
I I'm with you I'm with you but uh I
appreciate the call
yeah oh it's nice talking to you all
right there is Kevin from San Diego
let's go next to how about uh oh no I
don't want to go to this person I'm
getting a notification that their audio
is just a disaster let's go to uh
Guillaume from beautiful Montreal I I
understand you got snow last night
Guillaume
uh yes can you hear me right I can hear
you fine perfect and I'm not gonna say
it tonight because it's still coming in
ah it's still snowing
uh yep pretty pretty big one I'm
probably gonna have to shovel somewhere
tonight too beautiful
uh so how's the weather on your side the
weather's good uh no snow here but uh
you know uh I I don't remember when we
last spoke I am considering making my
next return to Montreal very very soon
as I have friends and family there and
it's been a while since I've been there
in winter last time I was there in
January my nose would instantly freeze
when I would step out into the street to
give a recommendation as to when maybe
closer to mid to end February well oh I
see that's all that's already better
uh the the weather at that point is
usually not less cold but less
aggressive okay
all right I'll try to make that happen
but this isn't about me what's on your
mind today
so the last couple times we talked um I
threw hypotheticals out there but
I it was mostly me trying to uh
formulate the best way I could and then
I decided to just wait after the midterm
speed so let's do not get accused of
trying to influence anything
uh but there was a question that came up
uh I was in Twitter a lot recently I
know my bad that's on me I guess uh and
a lot of the conversations uh ended up
uh moving towards people
attacking
the moderation of Twitter yeah working
along with the US government which I not
entirely sure they were that active with
they might have been in communication I
don't know
uh for censorship when most of what we
could see was essentially
the the the uh I'm not entirely sure
what agency would have worked with
Twitter that front but it was trying to
reduce the impact of Russian
misinformation on influencing the
midterms yeah
the question was well the problem first
the persons to whom I was talking to all
all about we should allow Russian
misinformation to affect the U.S
elections and whatnot and that brought
to me the major question of with the us
trying to push their nose until
literally every other country's economy
and uh government system and everything
maybe without necessarily trying to give
them a a vote or any actual power
why don't we
um trying to phrase it why don't you
guys more regularly consider what other
countries think about candidates
in terms of trouble but these there's
two different things here so there's
actually three different things here at
Guillaume so the first one is is there
not a hypocrisy in that the U.S has
interests in leaders around the world
and works to influence the way elections
go
occasionally or sometimes and yeah it
says it's wrong when other countries try
to do it to the U.S yes that is a double
standard but every country does that
every country wants to have a say about
their own leaders and to have a say
about everyone else's leaders so it's a
hypocrisy that is not unique to the
United States however the United States
has the resources to maybe better affect
what happens in other countries more so
than other countries that's number one
about it at times
sorry what was that Gail
I said some at times they can get really
aggressive about it I mean we're not
absolutely absolutely so there's one
thing it is a double standard okay yep
second part of it
shouldn't Americans care more what the
world thinks about the leaders we pick
my opinion is that the answer is yes now
that doesn't mean that people around the
world should get votes that's not what
I'm saying but for example when I think
about when George W Bush was president
and the world was essentially against
the invasion of Iraq and Republicans
here said that doesn't matter we do
what's best for us I think it would be
smarter and more sophisticated to say
well
it would be good to know why the world
is against this Invasion even though
ultimately we do what we do let's
actually think about that and similarly
when World opinion of trump was very low
and World opinion of Biden is higher
I don't say oh those are [ __ ] Europeans
who cares I say that's interesting I
want to know more about why because it's
important to me what the world thinks
about what we're doing here so to answer
that question the answer is absolutely
yes but these are sort of a couple
different things you're asking about
I guess
um there's the fact that I was not
entirely sure how to bring it up well
you did beautifully yeah you really did
I mean there's the whole uh there's the
whole aspect uh according to the people
I was talking to Russian misinformation
is all good all Gucci everything should
be accepted and seen as fact but oh you
then communist Canadians over there you
go there I mean
as it specifically applies to your
friend I I don't I don't find your
friend to be particularly you know
sophisticated in their thinking but but
I hope I've at least outlined a few of a
few of my thoughts I've got to run okay
I appreciate you calling yep have a
great day all right there we go always
good to hear from Guillaume from
Montreal let's try Bert from Jersey Bert
are you able to get right into your
question
yes I am you hear me okay David I hear
you fine okay thank you for taking uh
here's my question
um you know you hear a lot of trumpers
and Trump people you know uh they talk
about his accomplishments the country
was moving the right direction uh you
know all these subjective things that's
hard to deny what I don't understand is
if you look at Trump's fiscal record
right yep we are eight trillion more in
debt from him from from the beginning
when he started to where he is today
right he's supposed to be his financial
genius he's supposed to be the
businessman and yet he added more debt
in four years than any U.S president
ever in that history that time period so
like there's a lot of criticism of trump
and you know Stormy Daniels all you know
like a list goes on you never hear any
criticism of his financial record so why
is that and where is it well it's so
obvious you're saying economically
economically right we are eight trillion
poor after Trump than before him yeah I
mean listen most people don't even
understand the difference between the
debt and deficit and are confused about
reducing the deficit versus reducing the
debt and and so it's honestly ignorance
is a big reason why this conversation
isn't had more you say to someone hey uh
uh Biden reduced the deficit and then
they go no but the debt has continued to
increase right Biden slowed down the
rate at which the debt is increasing
you've lost people so a lot of this
quite frankly with that particular issue
is people don't know what's going on
they don't understand it and I've tried
so many times to explain the difference
but I do think there are easier metrics
to look at stock market GDP job creation
unemployment inflation consumer
confidence
et
cetera
and on average all of those do better
under Democratic president so I tend to
focus there
the thing is this they're they're big
accomplishment is that oh the
financially we were the economy was
booming everyone was doing great well no
we're not we're as a result of his
policies and him and uh cutting taxes
and increasing spending were 8 trillion
poor we the debt is higher without a
doubt but I I concede that there were
many economic indicators that were
strong under under Trump I just don't
think it had anything to do with Trump
being president if that makes sense
but um I guess he just you never hear
people criticize about this there's no
you don't no you're right and like I
said I think a lot of people don't don't
even understand the difference
I apologize let's keep it to one thing
today because I'm up against the clock
and I gotta run okay thank you all right
there we go uh it's a good question we
should be talking more about that people
don't even get it so you're sort of like
trying to tread water with people that
are trying to pull you under it's a sad
situation let's go to a break uh we will
take calls again and I apologize I
wasn't able to get to everybody
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get to audience emails
the mailbag for the week you can email
info davidpackman.com there are some
very aggressive ones this week and I
will let you know sometimes a tweet will
be used sometimes a YouTube comment
might be included or a Facebook comment
or whatever the case may be we start
today with Donnie via Facebook who and
I'm gonna try to do my best reading of
this that I can Donnie had an opinion
and wrote in shortly after the uh
midterm election and said suffer from
TDS much you pedo supporting libtard
goof go sniff a little kid like your
potato in Chief pedo Joe then go smoke
crack with Hunter and F some hookers you
and you is misspelled almost every time
effing libtard loser goof they then got
our Standard Auto response that you know
I'm not going to be writing them back
and then they wrote back get effed so
someone very much struggling with uh
emotions and that type of thing I do
often wonder like what type of job could
this person have could this be your
accountant for example where you go in
and they go listen uh I would advise you
to take the full 179
depreciation on your new 6 000 pound
vehicle
excuse me a second you pedo sniffing
sorry I'm just writing a message go get
a
are these people our doctors our
accountants Etc
uh or not just a question I don't know I
never know the answer next message is
another person on teaching transgender
this person wrote in and said You Lie
when you say they don't teach about
trans it happened to my son and daughter
at a young age you POS
who can't Define woman I don't know if
that's a question or a statement you
looked like such a loser on Michael
Knowles show laughable how smug of a
liberal you looked like and what's wrong
with singing our national anthem leave
then That's a classic you don't like it
leaf it's progressives like you who
change everything good in this country I
know it's like we have weekends now and
we have minimum standards for health
insurance and minimum standards for
Education
give me a break dude you're all sick and
yes I just paid 550 for gas and our
store said they were late getting
turkeys what guy talks about cooking a
beautiful chicken C you change
Traditions I I guilty is charged okay
for me
spending what is it six hours
with a turkey in the oven and then you
get it out and the dark meat is just
it's just not that good guys let's not
pretend like turkey's that great okay
and then you've got the breast and
you're slicing it and it's enormous and
your checking is it done or not
I say get yourself a couple of just
nicely sized pasture-raised organic
chickens beautifully crispy skin takes
45 to 75 minutes in the oven everybody's
happy it's just better I'm not telling
you to change your tradition I'm just
telling you it's better and by the way
plenty of turkeys at every grocery store
I've been going to okay Casey wrote In
Casey says David seeing that many of
Trump's hand-picked candidates
underperformed and a clear split in the
Republican party is about to materialize
do you think it's at all likely Trump
runs as an independent in 24. if the
Republican party and media turn against
him what do you think would happen if he
just took his base with him and started
his own party I doubt he'll do it or
that it would occur to him but it's
something I could see him doing if
nothing else out of pure narcissism I
think that that's actually the critical
part of this question
if Trump actually cared about the
Republican party we would all be saying
he would never do that he would never
run as an independent because it would
almost ensure even if he just brought
over 10 percent of the Republican vote
15 some small relatively small amount he
guarantees Democrats win but that's if
Trump cared about the Democratic the
Republican Party
Trump doesn't care
about the Republican Party
that's the reality and therefore I do
think it's possible that Trump might run
as an independent out of desperation out
of humiliation if indeed DeSantis just
outright defeats him in a primary I hope
it happens I think it would be a great
thing for the country in that it would
hurt both Trump and whoever is the
eventual Republican nominee I love it we
should encourage Trump to do it Ellen
Rhoden
uh about Maga as a mental illness this
is interesting Ellen says hey David a
few times on your show you've wondered
aloud about the cause of the Maga
condition you expressed concern that you
might be overstepping by calling out
their behavior if it's mental illness
that's causing it I think it's good
you're considering that it shows your
empathy but I also suspect you believe
as I do that they're caught their causes
are multiple and nuanced and you're
going to keep doing it because the
bottom line is we can't become apathetic
towards the movement I think the way you
handle them is fine very little mocking
there which is pretty impressive yeah
when we say
is Maga a mental illness in some of
those people I'm not laughing at it I
think we need to deal with mental
illness in this country if we determine
I mean listen
I want undiagnosed and untreated mental
illness to be diagnosed and to be
treated
that whatever it is and if that mental
illness is part of why someone Falls for
Maga delusion
it's good to treat it both because it's
better to help people when they're
struggling with mental illness and it
might prevent us from going down this
insane path of trumpism once again so I
appreciate Ellen's comment very much
Eric Rhoden are people like Mike Lindell
and Herschel Walker part of the Maga
grift or victims of it this is another
interesting perspective from Eric Eric
says hey David do you think people like
Mike Lindell and Herschel Walker are
knowingly part of the Maga grift or were
they victims of it what I mean is do
these mid-level front men know it's all
a grift or are they just patsies being
exploited due to their celebrity status
and psychological vulnerability for
example
I don't think Herschel Walker woke up
one morning and decided running for the
U.S Senate is the next logical step in
his professional and personal life
obviously somebody approached him with
the idea likewise Mike pillow is
destroying himself financially and seems
to be used by other people as a pawn and
ATM machine for I guess their own profit
and ambition the reason I ask this is
well we can't change the minds of Mega
followers directly it would be great if
we could find a way to wake up these
linchpin people to reality
yeah I uh I don't know the answer to
that Mike pillow seems like a True
Believer Herschel Walker kind of seems
like he might have been grifted in with
appeals to his narcissism and ego and
that's what you have to understand
ego is a common thing okay if you have a
show like mine on some fundamental level
you think your opinions are interesting
enough for other people to listen to
them rather than to just make their own
show right so like can it be denied that
on some level I must think well I don't
know what I have to say is at least
interesting enough that I should make a
show with elected officials this is
significantly bigger and we've looked at
traits of narcissism Etc and
what happens with a lot of these people
is they become convinced like Trump did
and apparently like Herschel Walker that
they're somehow needed by the country
that they're doing some great thing and
um I wonder whether at this point it's
too late for Herschel Walker to be
talked out of that he may soon be gone
if we do our job in uh in the state of
Georgia and uh we'll get back to that in
a moment interesting uh email from
Julian Julian says interesting subreddit
drama David an interesting segment for
the bonus show or something could be
reading replies on the conservative
subreddit very interesting to see what
some of them are saying about Trump
imagine he runs as an independent in 24
and splits the vote I recommend checking
this out as it reminds me of the betting
market segments in terms of indication
of conservative opinion yeah if you
check out the conservative subreddit
like reddit.com R conservative
you will find that there is a not
insignificant portion that is mad at
Trump
and ready to abandon Donald Trump now
what if anything it tells us about 24 I
think it's just way too early but it's
interesting let's deal with the December
runoff first Kerry wrote In
and said please come to Georgia
we need you
I am figuring out Carrie
how can I get as involved as possible in
Georgia given that I don't think I can
make it down there in the next few weeks
and we're going to be doing a bunch of
stuff critically important to get 51
rather than 50. imagine a supposed Red
Wave
in which Democrats gain a seat in the
Senate I mean that's just that's amazing
Brian Rhoden Brian has sad news and says
you lost a daily listener I'm sure you
don't care but I actually loved your
show prior to the last few days with all
your negativity which never happened
sorry need more positive in my life I
know you want to keep it real but holy
cow your negativity was the worst I'm
switching to Mighty Midas as I watched
them as well and they were dead on right
with all their content and even head on
a guess that nailed the election that
Fox News had made fun of their guest was
100 percent right
listen
I was
as honest as possible
in the lead up to the midterm
I said the momentum had shifted to
Republicans and that is indeed the case
what over the summer was looking like a
much bigger Democratic victory in the
Senate came down to just one or two
seats a lot of these races ended up way
closer look at fetterman odds way closer
than it was supposed to be in July I
correctly told you the momentum is going
to the Republicans and I said
the specific numbers may be skewed
because of right-wing poles that are
being included in the averages
I was very upfront
and the most important thing I said
was we're so close
that the polling no longer matters it's
about voting oh fetterman's up three or
down two doesn't matter
if we are allowed to vote in
Pennsylvania we vote in Pennsylvania
um so yes Brian is done with this show
because of that because of something I
guess that I don't really understand I
do appreciate all the very nice messages
I got from people saying David I think
you struck the right balance between
this is the polling here are the
limitations here's what might be going
on and making sure that everybody votes
that was the critical uh um message and
enough people did including 18 to 29
year olds that the Red Wave ended up
being potentially a Ripple uh we have a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at joinpakman.com and of course we will
be back Monday with much much much more